hey this is Moshe kasher and Natasha
Leggero we just got married six months
ago which we think pretty much makes us
qualified to give love advice to
strangers so that's what we did we
packed up the car hit the road spread
the love
in the back that's the same person who's
been raising your hand my whole set who
I've been purposely ignoring well this
probably won't go well I'm warning you
right now oh thank you thank you come
here come here oh you're not wearing
shoes so this is definitely a good old
Vegas white girl night all right do you
have a problem with your love life that
you actually need help with or do you
just want to say hi my love life yeah
but I probably should be cool okay cool
thank you for coming okay honey let's
give it what's your name my name is
Gretchen and you're so Oh Gretchen okay
I got it change her name you'll find
love next how much I'm looking at this
hotel in Amsterdam do you care that it
looks like a Hilton Garden Inn when
you're in the middle of Amsterdam yeah
no I don't it's free right
yes apiece in the sink hotel no it's
between it's just it's not charming I'm
just saying your face it's a nice hotel
room what you wanted to be on the bed in
a wooden shoe kind of I mean you're in
Amsterdam and then you're like can I
have my still first microwave
grilled cheese there's a microwave in
there there's like a slip mat on the
bathtub what do you want the bath
there's fluorescent lighting you want
like to sink your feet into like a four
inch thick layer of beluga caviar in the
bathtub
no I just let something that feels like
we're in Amsterdam and not Akron trying
to make it the same no I expected what
you did for me it's like that's a
perfectly nice hotel and it's free and
we should just stay there and save our
money and spend it on going to dope
restaurants and maybe even that thing
that we talked about maybe doing an
issue damn
that you said that if I behaved myself
and cleaned up that you would be
- what's that the thing that we talked
about about Amsterdam
a prostitute I don't like calling them
that we didn't talk about that I was I
meant to bring it up so you're saying if
we get to stay in this shitty hotel I
don't want to stay in that we can
finally get a prostitute for the
relationship we can save our money and
then we can she could sleep in that bed
what's your name my name is Lacey hi
Lacey that's cute and what's what's your
name Dave Lacey and Dave Dave how long
have you guys been dating for years and
are you married no no how old are you
guys I'm 30 she's 23 and you've been
together four years that's what's up
dawg Dehlia bro you gotta get him when
they're a young lady together for four
years I talk about marriage and he
doesn't want to talk about it wait a
minute
dude here's your like you robbed the
cradle and then you're like I don't
think we should complete building the
cradle I think you're the guy that got
her all young and she spent her whole
adult life with you it's really not
about me it's she's 23
you think eventually she's gonna look
over you'll be like dude you're old as
goodbye Gretchen where are you
let's party
it's been waiting how many male comics
do you know who have a baby who are
touring four hundred well how many
female comics do you know with a baby
who are touring as Seto zero not one
because the male comics are like sitting
at home and then all of a sudden I quit
they're like Hello I'll take it piece
and then they call it you're like this
brain you have to put the like Bag Balm
on her on her belly the one look-back
bomb don't you get out of that like
utter cream and you put it on her belly
so that she doesn't get stretch marks or
she can do that herself
honestly that and in a real talk if you
get stretch marks during the like
pregnancy boom I'm out divorce what
makes you think that this is the man you
want to marry like you have so much like
when I was 23 I was like living in
Australia with a con artist like I it
takes so long to figure out your life
like what makes you think this is the
man you want to spend the rest of your
life with we've lived together for like
three years and everything is going well
so far so why not wait Lacey's saying
that makes sense is if if they were to
get married it would make her think okay
this is now I can kind of see my future
this is what's gonna be happening but
the fact that he doesn't want to get
married is making her feel like oh I'm
insecure I don't know what's gonna
happen I just want him to talk about it
he doesn't even want to talk about marry
well there's no better place to talk
about it than here at the beauty bar in
front of 200 drunk strangers
hell yeah yeah by the way you're 30 what
do you want from life just be a
professional kid that's oh he wants to
be a produce no kid I mean the biggest
it's just so everything I can't handle
all it needs is rats then I would be
like not your perfect storm completely
unable to be here Dave you don't have to
commit to marrying her but you have to
commit to going to couples counseling
with her to talk about marriage
do they have therapists in Las Vegas no
there's no therapist in Las Vegas are
you into therapy would you do that there
were any kissing Vegas then yes okay
would you be open to talking about it
maybe even in just a couple session two
sessions really would do anything for
her Oh Dave who cares how old someone is
it doesn't always matter it's not like
everything goes in a certain way and
then Dave I like Dave hey you got out of
here with your judgment Dave Dave Dave
Dave Dave Dave really there's no there's
no rules here try to live beyond rules
in your life for once you know I think
that's true Dave you're thinking about
so much allows you to be an eternal kid
in a way and maybe you need what she has
to offer you've been dating Lacey since
she was literally a kid and it's time
for you
the perpetual kid to you know to talk
about it you don't have to commit to
doing it but you have to commit to
talking about it deal deal we got